Denzel Ward the Browns rookie defensive
back great start to the season and got a
win last night take me into the locker
room after the game Denzel what was it
like yellows excite everybody's energy
was just well we're just feeling
everybody's by they're just very
appreciative of the win and we don't
want to stop here we just looking
forward to the next game they got to
continue to get better and run ball game
well you're from Ohio you know what it's
like to be a Browns fan right you know
that pain right and you know so you can
understand how these these fans reacted
and they felt like it was the Super Bowl
last night yeah yeah it's been a while
since the Browns got a win like I said
the team and the fans were just very
appreciative it was a hard-fought win so
we just got to keep it rolling what was
it like when you saw Baker come into the
game I was excited I know Baker is a
great player a great quarterback he came
and very confident he showed that what
time did you get to bed last night no I
didn't fall asleep till late maybe like
2:00 in the morning I could excited
about the win and I love the uniforms
what do you guys think of those oh yeah
I love those unified wear those every
game though yeah yeah yeah and don't
mess with the streak I mean where I'm
until you guys lose right yeah I like
those uniforms so I'm looking forward to
wearing those again what was your game
plan on Sam darn 'old oh really is more
so about us and just doing our
assignments that take care of it
celebrate there but you guys were
studying the film well but what did you
want him to see it because it felt like
Coach Williams was gonna probably design
a lot of things or maybe look like
something but it was it was not he was
disguising his defenses is that right
guys just trying to confuse them really
a lot of disguises and trying to get
pressure on them as much as possible how
would you describe the difference
between a college wide receiver in a pro
wide receiver
definitely the game is a lot faster from
college to the pros and receivers are a
lot more experienced here in the NFL and
the way they run their routes a lot of
receivers are very crafty so it's a
difference between a college receiver
and an NFL receiver I would say
definitely what did you learn from the
Hard Knocks experience oh I don't really
pay too much attention to hard an
otologist focus really on practice I
wasn't to focus on the cameras they're
trying to do anything different did they
want you to like you had a choice
whether you wanted to be involved in it
or not oh no not really I mean you're
going to be involved the cameras were
everywhere so I understand me personally
I wasn't really focus on trying to be on
camera
moreso focus on how to how we're gonna
win ball game are you guys watching game
film today I know we actually have today
y'all gave us a day off what are you
gonna do now watch them film I like that
I like that a little bit you know
getting some some homework some extra
credit there from the coach who do you
expect to be the quarterback against the
Oakland Raiders oh that's that's
definitely the coach's decision well we
just have to wait and see wait wait wait
Denzel I know that's a veteran response
there but as a rookie who do you think
will be the quarterback who do you not
the who does coach I think how do you
yeah I think it's gonna be Baker may
still of tie-rod he had got hurt and
they say he had got a contestant so
right now the next quarterback is Baker
Mayfield and he's proven that he could
come in and win ballgames so I'll
definitely say Baker will probably start
the game out this upcoming ended well
Congrats on the start you're the real
deal a cornerback and you know I think
you guys got something special going on
defense and maybe with Baker you get a
boost in there offensively and it's been
a good start for the Browns so congrats
so far Denzel thanks for joining us
thank you I appreciate it no Denzel Ward
for more Dan Patrick show to the audio
2:39 on Direct TV or download the Dan
Patrick show app
[Music]